hi I'm Giga and I just spent $400 for a
[ __ ] JPEG in the world of mobile
games is a weird and twisted one that
generally doesn't conjure up the best of
images misleading ads basic gameplay
generic sponsorship reads from some
[ __ ] youtuber trying to make a quick
buck your white folks amigo back to the
game [ __ ] if this place has been memes
and watts by pretty much the entire
gaming community in the past few years a
sub-genre of the mobile gaming world has
been gaining a loss of popularity gotcha
games bake round order has your lane
Fire Emblem heroes dokkan battle if you
can hang around the anime community for
long enough I'm sure you've at least
heard of one of these because you know
someone who sold their soul to one of
these games and if not you've definitely
seen him Tiger gingy's of them because
there's a lot of them like a lot of hand
side and it's really good as well I
don't know what point I was trying to
make well gotcha isn't limited to anime
a huge portion of weeds of playing them
and they're making numbers that can't be
ignored as of right now beta has made
over four billion dollars and was the
most talked about game on Twitter in
2019 beating out the lights of Smash
Bros Final Fantasy and fortnight's while
I personally dabbled in them I've voice
stopped myself from getting into deep
because my preconceived perceptions talk
to anyone in the community and it's
always about salt spending money in self
deprecating means still quick google
search you see articles about stories of
addiction the man who spent seventy
thousand dollars on fates goal or
another guy who spent over six thousand
dollars getting one character and grand
blue fantasy it's kind of mental
basically almost everything you hear
makes you wonder why anyone would even
want to get into these games so most of
the information i've gotten from the
various references of made in my videos
have been through talking to many of my
friends over their experiences for bits
but I wanted to change that I wanted to
see what the deal with these games were
despite a community that seemed to be
built on a foundation of sodium chloride
inform those of you who have never
played before what the gotcha game
experience is actually like and really
pin down how and why people could spend
a large amount of money
to become Wales why would anyone
actually spend hundreds of dollars for a
PNG is the secrets really just cute
anime girls this is my journey them to
the bottomless pits that is gotcha hell
hell is only a word
the reality is much
and now we're gonna financially recover
from this now you may be thinking wow
Giga that was a really long intro bar
you sure you didn't just make this video
as an excuse to fund your addiction for
cute anime girls no this was for science
science I really wanted to immerse
myself in the world of Gacha
but to understand the way or I needed to
become the way or breathe its air swim
in its ocean consume the same diet of
high rarity SSR anime titties so I sets
myself a budget of $1,000 which by
everyday standard seems way too much
money to be spending on anime p.m. geez
it wasn't and in the wide world of Gacha
it's not really that much at all we'll
get back to that later but first a quick
word from today's sponsor who funded me
on the street endeavor
no.1 I did this I did this to me but
thrill though even though I could have
been sponsored by many of the games I'm
about to talk about I decided against it
because I didn't want any sponsorships
to be able to influence what I can say
in this video and more importantly I
didn't want you to think that anything I
did say in this video has been affected
in other words I am NOT making my money
back in this video I just thought it
would be funny for you to see me blow a
thousand bucks so with that said here
were the ground rules I wouldn't play
any game I've been sponsored by before
for the same reasons and I wouldn't
spend money for the sake of spending
money I didn't want to just blindly
throw cash away for no reason but if
there was something I really wanted I
would truly try to get it and not limit
my spending like I would usually do
basically if I was going to whale I
needed a reason to whale so with that in
mind I set up a fresh PayPal accounts
put a thousand bucks in it and um I
would just play until the money ran out
this really did sound like a good idea
in my head when I started this video
before we go any further though for
those of you not them know I should
probably explain what a gotcha game even
is the term Gacha game refers to the
digital implementation of the Gacha pond
the ban by trademark apps you a toy
dispenser they are kind of like toy
vending machines they can find
essentially all over Japan the basic
principle is that you have a standard
pool of prizes which you can insert
money into to get one of them with no
guarantee of which one it would be if
it's not the one you were aiming for
then tough luck you've got to put more
money
and try again it was only a matter of
time before someone had the bright idea
to implement this on a wider scale
digitally and that's exactly what's
happened
dragon collection is often credited as
being the first Gacha game it was a card
battle game where he'd amass prize for
playing the game and completing quests
and opening chests but that's not really
important because what's really
important is that you make an army a
[ __ ] ton of [ __ ] monies nowadays
modern gotcha games implements a wide
range of different systems but the core
mechanics remain the same using some
form of digital currency whether it be
earned through playing the game or with
real money or both to pull from a finite
pool of prizes to obtain units or
equipment that can be used in game which
can be referred to as rolling or pulling
or summoning so basically when you hear
about gotcha games and you hear about a
bunch of grown-ass men sinking the life
savings to obtain a super rare PNG of
the favorite anime girl this isn't true
at all they sink their money into the
chance of obtaining a super a PNG of
their favorite anime girl which is far
more logical and that is the world I was
about to enter
the first step was choosing a gotcha
game to play which um was definitely an
easy choice to say that there are a lot
of gotcha games like saying that there
are a lot of stars in the sky or plate
has a reasonable number of anime
adaptations there's pretty much a game
for every niche and popular franchise
from turn-based strategy to rhythm games
card games classic JRPGs so it wasn't
exactly lacking in choice I wanted to
experience the spectrum so initially I
made a list of about seven games that I
wanted to try out from various different
genres and franchises so I downloaded
them all and said alright let's get
started hmm so why was the [ __ ] idiot
in my mind I thought this is gonna be
easy download some anime games blow a
bunch of cash trying to obtain some big
fat anime titties document my results
wham bam get them easy YouTube views but
then I quickly realized that by far the
biggest investment I would have to give
wasn't actually money it was time so me
being the genius latter was starting
seven games at once at the beginning my
days would look something like this
alright time to do my daily missions
[Music]
okay time to sleep these aren't the
types of games you can marathon for 40
hours and complete they are designed to
be played in small bursts for a very
long time after about a week I was in
serious danger of burning out or getting
admitted to a psychiatric hospital so I
cut my losses and whittled it down to
three games that stood out to me the
most arc Knight reguarly you lost and
brain shadow be [ __ ] with you is fake
okay why fate go because the gee-gees
are better in context okay there I said
it
are you happy while three games wasn't
the initial sample size I was hoping for
I feel it was more than enough to give
me a general idea of the structure
because whatever the game played the
basic gotcha formula was always
identical the beginning of every gotcha
game issue with the sensory overload
with enough shiny notifications to make
you feel like an ADHD diagnose magpie
after doing a line of coke it is just a
cluster of information overload even now
look at some of the menus of some fresh
gotcha games I'm not familiar with and I
think to myself so what the [ __ ] am I
supposed to click to start playing the
game I didn't know what the hell I was
supposed to be doing but apparently it
didn't matter because the matter what
you click or what you end up doing the
game will reward you with enough virtual
currency to rival or a Nigerian prince
free gold free gems free material I
didn't know what half the things before
what I could buy whether the game was
trying to button me up with resources or
if I just found myself in a mr. beast
video this is what I call the welfare
stage of a gotcha game at this point it
doesn't really matter what you do you
can pretty much play the game for as
much as you want with no worry and just
enjoy the game for the game if you think
this generosity will last forever
however well eventually you're gonna hit
the wall after a few weeks you'll find
that you're missing some kind of
resource that inhibits your ability to
progress further your first instinct is
to probably assume that you need better
units where you don't have enough daily
stamina which in gotcha games is the
resource that's used when you play it
bored I found was that it was the
materials that would enable you to level
up your units to a point where they were
strong enough to take on mid to late
game content and you know forget
everything you've heard about the gotcha
game experience from secondhand
conversations because this is where the
real gotcha experience begins let's talk
about farming when people
gotcha games they always talk about
spending money and rolling for their
waifu's but for some reason nobody
really talks about the actual activity
you'll be spending most of your time
doing see when you think of traditional
JRPGs the more you play the game the
more you grinds the more exp you gain to
level up your characters but in gotcha
games you have to use some kind of
resource to do this and then to level up
your characters beyond certain points
you noticed that you need special
materials that haven't just been gifted
to you in the welfare period so you
start doing research about how to get
them and then you notice that if you
replace certain stages there's a
percentage that these materials will be
dropped which we refer to as a drop rate
so you start replaying the same stage
over and over to get the materials you
need and this can take time so you start
thinking whom I wonder if there's a way
to optimize this now you could
deteriorate your brain farming the same
stage for days or you could wait for
special events where rare materials are
given away in a much more generous rate
there you can get by doing war farming
this is where the game turns from casual
time sync it's a part-time job is you
spend as much stamina as you possibly
can to take advantage of the fact that
you get a river and blocks in a few
minutes rather than a few days basically
making farming a higher priority than
any life essential activity and thank
you our first recording your stamina
sanity because mine definitely needed
refreshing after farming of summer
events between constraints people often
talk about getting too deep into gotcha
games and I thought oh yeah that's
probably when they start spending their
life savings trying to get the newest
shiny SSR units so here I was thinking I
was getting into a glorified waifu
collector open wallets ready to spend
some cash to get that 2d ass and then
when i finally got into it what I've
really found myself doing was
researching how to get sorted materials
looking up guides and then somewhere
along the lines I ended up thinking to
myself how the [ __ ] did a game about
collecting waifu's end up with me
looking up spreadsheet or percentage
drop rates of different stages and
precise farming guides for events so I
can maximize my daily stamina so I can
get the materials that I wanted and that
was the exact moment I realized I was in
too deep now I've realized that I've
been talking for about Jesus 2,500 words
already and I haven't made gotcha games
sound like the most appealing prospect
and I think I'm starting to understand
why the community so self-deprecating
because I legit
we had a fun time playing them one of
the biggest problems mobile games have
is that it's really hard to make them
look exciting from an outsider
perspective like aside from something
like Hong Kong impact 3 you can't really
have an epic gaming montage that's why
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you doing I'm gaming so I know
the guy reaction when you hear anyone
talking positively about these kinds of
mobile games is to assume that is some
kind of sponsored ad read but I'm not
lying when I say a lot of these games
are actually really fun and have
legitimately interesting gameplay but
that can be really hard to tell at first
and that's because beginning content is
so easy you can pretty much be played by
paraplegic toddler wearing a blindfold
interpreting controls with a USB
steering wheel and they could still do a
full three-star clear without breaking a
sweat so it's really hard to gauge the
depth of the gameplay without putting a
considerable amount of time in yourself
to get to later game content like okay
let's take our class as an example on
the surface it looks like a pretty
simple tower defense game with anime
waifu's pick up your units plop them
down and sit back let it autoplay and
just watch some anime pngs beat the [ __ ]
out of each other but as you start
progressing the game keeps throwing new
elements of you there are new enemy
types new tiles you can start placing
blocks down every unit has a different
specialty of different ability which can
be activated manually during the game
you have limited deployment points and
if you let the unit die you completely
lose all those points so sometimes
you're treating a units at just the
right moment is the difference between
winning and losing a stage throw this
all together you can sometimes get
clutch moments where you feel like
you're in a diamond ranked Korean
Starcraft madrigals and micromanaging
that you're doing and that's to me was
when the game started to get really
funny when you probably start learning
the depth of the game mechanics start
strategizing and having to perfectly
execute a strategy in game I didn't care
too much about the story or the
challenge of clearing every stage kept
me coming back aside from that there are
plenty of other reasons I had tons of
fun with the other games regalia loss
had some really good design all around
and the soundtrack was just [ __ ]
godly no seriously it should be illegal
for a mobile game to have a soundtrack
of this good cuz to me it's like the
persona 5 of gotcha game soundtracks
pretty much every track you hear from
the menu themes the battle soundtrack is
a [ __ ] banger and I often just wanted
to play the game just so I can listen to
the music and as for Fate go well it was
the oldest game so the gameplay in
design did feel a bit dated
comparatively and yet it was the game I
got to most invested in and it's funny
because I went into it thinking Oh fate
yeah I know fate where every female
historical figure you've ever known is
the hot girl and every male
go figure you've never known as a hot
girl and sometimes worse or a lolly what
else is there to know but then I played
and I had forgotten that I'd originally
thought the entire premise of fate was
super interesting I actually got really
invested in the world again and while
the story starts off pretty generic the
later chapters developed into something
comparable to the original visual novels
so with all that said and done you may
have noticed that for a video titled I
spent a thousand dollars and gotcha game
saying you don't have to I haven't
talked much about spending money at all
yet and that's because at this point I
hardly had or felt the need to I'd spend
a fair amount of time playing these
games already and the only thing I had
bought was the beginner pack from arc
nights I was legitimately concerned that
I had gone about this video all wrong
and I wouldn't be able to spend close to
the budget I set even if I tried and
then there were some wifey's I wanted
and it all went downhill from there
[Music]
mobile games have been around for long
enough that the general monetization
model is pretty well known now and I
think because of that there's a stigma
that a lot of these games are kind of
paid to win but with the specific games
I played I didn't really see that we've
enough of an understanding the games
could be cleared with low rarity in 3d
units and there would always be a system
where you could generate enough premium
currency to be able to save up to get
stronger units to help you so aside from
some super hard challenge modes you
aren't really locked out of any contents
by being free-to-play and while there
were exp packs of the likes that you can
buy to help save you some time I never
really felt the need to spend huge
amounts of money on them I don't think
there's a better example that
illustrates this than fate go because
you cannot pay to get rid of any of the
grinding getting stronger unis doesn't
even make the process go any faster it
just means you have to grind more to
level them up the only thing you can use
your cash for is to refill your stamina
but nobody does this because it's far
more efficient just to wait for special
events when you are given a lot of rare
rare materials and only a [ __ ] madman
would use their Saints ports for
anything other than rolls why because
it's not pay to win it's pay to waifu
and guess what I ended up spending most
of the budgets of this video on
[Music]
that's right we're like 15 minutes into
this video right now and I finally get
to talk about spending money for some
PNG waifu's to some it may blow your
mind how a PNG could hold enough value
that anyone would want to spend a
significant amount of money to obtain it
but when you're on this game
continuously every day for a decent
amount of time where a large portion of
that time is you watching your PNG units
to PNG stuff a decent-looking PNG
doesn't start to seem like a bad idea
basically a whole lot of things can
happen to make the value of a PNG go up
enough that you would want it for
example after playing arclights for a
while I saw this banner up on 4 chip I
really want Texas because I have nothing
better than a 4-star band died on my
team so is my weakest role that had to
fill out and also she's hot and I also
really wanted Loveland because she's one
of the best guards in the game with the
ability to silence which is really
really use of some of the later stages
in the game and also she's hot
and then the Schwartz banner came out
and then well I didn't really need her
but she was in a swimsuit and it was the
summer event and also she's hot oh yeah
I should probably explain what a banner
is like a traditional Gacha machine the
prize pool and virtual gotchas are
massive so the chance of you getting the
exact units you want by just randomly
rolling is miniscule especially if it's
a high rarity unit to offset this gotcha
games normally have rotating banners
where certain units on the banner have a
higher probability of showing up than
usual so instead of having an abysmal
chance of rolling exactly who you want
you have a slightly less but still
abysmal chance of rolling exactly who
you want some people even plan months
ahead serving up their virtual currency
for upcoming banners which pretty much
guarantees that you'll never ever get
the character you're actually aiming for
when you want them in a Universal
mechanic called rate up is a lie or
alternatively you can be completely
satisfied with everything you have
before a hot new banner suddenly gets
released and you just feel like
which took me inevitably to the gutter
itself this is all right this is what
you're here for
all right who is it who is it as much as
I was enjoying the games I knew there
would come a point when I would have to
sell my soul to the gotcha Lords and so
I started with the ark Knights I bought
the most expensive Knights nine dollar
premium currency pack to see what it
would actually get me and what the
experience of rolling would actually be
like now in Ark Knights six stars is the
highest rôti that you can go and the
chance of getting a six star is 2% while
the chance of getting a five star is a
mere 4% did I get to six dollars I
didn't see nice again let's go holy six
so this is me getting to six dog units
and the five star unit in a single roll
of ten and I remember feeling like I was
high and enough cocaine to OD a baby
elephant and that's when I realized oh
oh this is dangerous I've been to a
casino exactly three times in my life
and it was a okay experience I don't
think it was really my scene
so I can wholeheartedly say that getting
the waifu you are aiming for felt way
better than winning money why come on
come on this is it this is it
yeah I have no [ __ ] clue it doesn't
make any logical sense to me either okay
like even [ __ ] leave this [ __ ] like
what what can you do with this eat pay
your rent survive it doesn't even have a
[ __ ] swimsuit edition what the [ __ ]
the point and I know some of my brains
up here like look dude I know human
evolution didn't create dopamine so you
can get off at the sight of getting some
SSR anime titties which is why I think
it is important to be aware of the
possible dangers it's easy to get
addicted to the feeling of rolling and
with no limiter to how much money confer
into the Gacha system this can pile up
really quickly limited banners make you
feel the urge to get a yearly before
it's not available anymore it's a sales
tactic that's the Saudis time so you
should definitely keep this in mind
before starting to spend any money
because if you
don't keep track of it or set yourself a
limit you can find yourself spending far
more than you really should
we're not every game is the same when it
comes to the sin genus of the Gacha
system would you Galia loss dealers just
giving away free rolls and I was getting
all the unit's I needed before I can
even think about spending any money and
with dark nights I feel it was a fair
balance between me getting the unit's I
was actually aiming for and me
recklessly overspending because I didn't
feel like it needed anything close to
the most expensive pack that I bought
but I had yet to take on the final boss
of gotcha some bling ring's that's right
bait go in fate go the chance of running
for the highest rarity 5 star servants
is 1% so the chance of you actually
rolling for the exact 5 star servants
you want is less than 1% that's why to
me fate is the final boss of gotcha and
as much as I held it off when I saw that
there was a special fate apocrypha
events coming up and as someone who's
watched apocrypha and enjoyed it I knew
my time had come there were some
servants that I wanted first up was
Mordred to me she was always the
superior sabo cuz I've got a soft spot
for spunky arrogance anime girls and
also she's hot and the second was of
course a stove oh look it wasn't for the
memes okay just go watch fate Apocrypha
and tell me that a stall pho isn't clear
as [ __ ] all right yes I wanted a Stoffer
okay cuz you know what
sometimes it takes a real man to become
best girl the targets were simple
Mordred and a stole faux anything else
would be a nice little bonus I'd saved
up enough free Saints quartz which is
the premium currency of the game i
streamed it from our patreon discord
server so I could share my salt
I knew my chances and I knew what was
coming next
under overwhelming odds there is only
one thing I can do
I got a whale with a [ __ ] out of this
dear gotcha lords please bless this roll
with good waifu's and good gotcha luck
and I will be a good weed from now on I
swear to God
Mordred was a 5 star so I thought it
would be better to go for the harder one
at first so I started rolling and I got
her on my second 10 roll
come on so this was a good [ __ ] role
I have oh I'm sure some of you fake-o
veterans well right now be cursing me
for my luck because at this point I
hadn't even spent any money and looking
back I probably should have quit while I
was ahead should I have just given up
while I was ahead and I was winning but
all that was left was a stall pho which
was a level of rarity servant so this
was going to be easy right right so I
rolled oh my god why and I rolled again
another one I'm going at five now and I
roll again man now look now that I'm
doing this 20 bucks for one 10 roll
isn't it's quite a lot and I kept
rolling but you know who I got not
[ __ ] a stall for but you know what I
was gonna let that faze me as seaman
from gurren lagaan once said if it's not
0% then it's basically the same as a
hundred percent with a credit card I
think that was exactly what he said
don't quote me on that so I knew what I
had to do it was time for me to stop
holding back take my training weights
off and power up to my final form
forgive me wallet but just this once I
must go all out
[Music]
okay if I'm doing this I'm going all the
way so you're telling me there's a
chance it's funny because I have viewed
this on the other side well I'm just
like why are you getting so excited over
a [ __ ] PNG I don't get it did I get a
mine gotcha heaven or gotcha he'll never
tell me the odds Oh saver well Siegfried
no bad that's a lot of damage
oh come on Siegfried again if it's it
freed again I'm gonna follow my god this
isn't fun we're done when I say we're
doing
[Music]
doing
[Music]
finally oh my god
[Music]
that was a few weeks ago and now I think
I'm ready to put a stop in this journey
overall I've spent zero dollars on
regalia lost $150 and Ark nights and six
hundred and fifty dollars on fate go 400
of which was getting a stole phone $400
$400 he isn't even that good of a
servant it's a tier 3 4 star I spent
$400 on a dick in terms of value for
money I was pretty satisfied with what I
got for Ark nights I spent way more
recklessly than I normally would have
but I got pretty much everything I was
aiming for and way more than I needed
and that's four faiths while I do have
some pretty decent units to show for it
I do feel like it definitely wasn't
worth the money I put into it so what
did I learn from this journey
whoever said gotcha games were like
drugs was a [ __ ] liar
cuz drugs are way cheaper but also as
hard as I tried I couldn't spend the
thousand dollars in the timespan I was
given sorry guys you got click baited I
really was prepared to spend the whole
budget for this video and if I had kept
on playing for a few months I'm sure
that would have been some character or
banner that would have caught my eye
that would have made it easy for me to
use up the remainder of the money but I
don't feel like it would have added
anything more for the purpose of this
video so I didn't see the point of
holding out I had a really fun time
getting into these games I'm Way past
the point where I needed to play them
for the purposes of this video and I'm
still playing them it definitely changed
a lot of my perspective when it comes to
mobile games and the reputation that
they have I came in cautious of the
predatory monetization systems you hear
about and while I can definitely see
some of it in action with some of the
Gotcha systems I was certainly surprised
how little we hear about the positive
experiences you can find here I think
have to treat them differently than you
do traditional games where you pay a set
amount and you get to set experience
because what impressed me the most is
how flexible gotcha games were it really
does cater to every kind of playstyle
for every kind of player you can
legitimately get away with being a
free-to-play player investing just a
small amount of
time each day and be able to clear all
the content that's available eventually
while having a fun time doing so there
is hours and hours and hours of free
content which has a lot of love and
passion put into it that you can enjoy
without spending a single penny but if
you don't have the willpower it is
incredibly easy to start dumping large
amounts of money into it so I think the
most important lesson is your mentality
when approaching these games if you know
you have an addictive personality who
wants to collect everything it probably
isn't the best idea for you to get into
these games and you should also never
get into them with the intention of
beating them because that's almost
[ __ ] impossible
instead our best I think you should come
into these games with the mentality that
they're just a casual time-sink a fun
thing to do when you have a free few
minutes to grind away with the
occasional longer session if you want to
play out the story or event quests the
amount you invest both the time and
money is completely up to you so set
yourself a limits enjoy it in moderation
definitely don't spend beyond your means
and you'll have a pretty fun time in the
grounds world of gotcha games $1000 is
hardly anything and there are people out
there who spend thousands or even tens
of thousands of dollars and still don't
have everything that they want so
remember there will always be a bigger
whale no matter how much you think you
whale you Amelia deformed dolphin
swimming in your shitty little fish tank
while somewhere out there there exists a
Leviathan or maybe a world serpent who
digivolve into a galaxy spanning tengen
toppa gurren lagaan
who the [ __ ] knows because no matter
what your opinion of the Gacha system is
if there's one thing I can appreciate is
that it's nothing if not transparent and
that's why the culture to me makes the
feed sense much of the community so
self-deprecating because we knew exactly
what we were getting into when we
started this we chose this we did this
to ourselves so now I truly do know
that's hell I walked into and now that
this video is done and I have no more
reason to stay in the Gotcha health and
I purposely threw myself into for the
purpose of my own curiosity I have just
one problem how the [ __ ] do I get out
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much
to Annie calm water the we balaji
podcast ie vido week 0 98 Joe Augustine
and everyone else to my patron to help
you to support my gaturro addiction I
mean made this video possible if you two
would like to support my journey into
gotcha health and her consider
supporting me on patreon - for real
though I couldn't make a video like this
without your support so I'm definitely
not gonna make the money back on this
video but that's fine that's the reason
I've been taking some extra sponsorships
on the side so I can be a bit more
experimental on a content I'm making on
a video like this because if you didn't
notice for the last month I didn't
really upload anything and that's
because I was mainly using the time to
explore new kinds of content like this
so don't think this is the only thing
I've been working on I'm really excited
to show you the other things that I've
used the time to experiment on because
we've so many anime being on break right
now I thought it would be the perfect
time to take a short break from watching
it myself
and so I've used this time to really try
to explore new ideas that I've had for a
while so I hope you guys enjoy what I've
been working on but anyway that's it
from me
I've been gig up and I will see you all
next time when I hopefully don't find
another hole that I'm gonna fall into
and have no idea how I'm gonna escape
from that's definitely not gonna happen